معركه بين تويتر وابل والاخيره تهدد بحذف
التطبيق الازرق عرض حقائق جديده حول جريمه
مقتل عائله في السودان والفيفا يحسم الجدل
حول هدف رونالدو في شباك الاوروغواي هذه
الاخبار وغيره نقولها لكم من قناه العربيه
اهلا بكم
من جديد على المليار الامريكي لاثير الضجه
واسعه بتصريحاته هذه المره باتهام شركه
ابل بانها تهدد بحذف تويتر من متجر
التطبيقاتها اب ستور الملك الجديد لتويتر
قال في تغريدات ان صناع ايفون قد توقفوا
عن الاعلان على تويتر مما دفعه للتساؤل عن
ما اذا كانت الشركه التكنولوجيا تكره حريه
التعبير في امريكا مضيفا ان ابل هددت بحجب
المنصه من اب ستور دون اخباره بسبب في
مكان ماسك قد وجه انتقادات واسعه لصناع
الايفون من بينها ان الشركه تفرض الرسوما
على مبيعاتها عبر متجر الخاص
بعد ما هزت جريمه بشعه ارجاء السودان راح
ضحيتها ام واثنان من ابنائها رميا بالرصاص
في منزلهم وسط الخرطوم كشفت شرطه العاصمه
في بيان الجديد ان العائله قتلت بمسدس
الاب الشرطه واكدت في بيانها ان التحريات
ما زالت متواصله لكشف الدوافع وتحديد
المتهم فيما قال احد اقاربي رب الاسره في
تصريحات للعربيه ان الابى لم يعاني من ايه
مشاكل نفسيه او نزاعات مع احد تؤدي الى
هذا الانتقام المر على حد وصفه وذلك بعد
تداول انباء ان تفيدو بان رب الاسره هو
المتهم الاساسي في هذه القضيه
والاخبار المونديال هذه المره حيث قرر
الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم احتساب الهدف
الاول الذي سجله منتخب البرتغال على
الاورغواي باسم برونو فرنانديز وليس
كريستيانو رونالدو وفي التفاصيل كان
اللاعب فرنانديز قد لعب كره عرضا لرونالدو
لكن هل لم تلمس الدون لتدخل شباك سيرجيو
روشيه حارس اوروغواي في الدقيقه الرابعه
والخمسين خصوصا ان الاعاده الدقيقه للحظه
تسجيل الهدف اكدت ان الكره لم تلمس راس
رونالدو فيما فازت البرتغال في هذه
المباراه بهدفين نظفين لتتاهل الى الدور
الثامن النهائي
وفي المونديال ايضا قال مدرب المنتخب
البرازيليه المعروف ان عائلته تبحث عن
مشجع عربي لرد الجميل له نظيره مساعدته
لها على حمل طفلهم عقب انتهاء مباراه
سامبا وصربيا الخميس الماضي مقاطع فيديو
متداوله على السوشيال ميديا اظهرت شابا
يحمل العالم الفلسطيني يحمل على كتفه طفلا
متعبا بعد خروج الجماهير من ملعب المباراه
ليتبين لاحقا انه حفيد المدرب البرازيلي
الذي قال ان الشاب عرض على زوجته وابنته
حمل الطفل الصغير الذي كان نائما لان
المسافه كانت طويله جدا على حد قوله
وفي خبرنا الاخيره فدت وسائل الاعلام
تركيا بان شاب تركيه دخل المستشفى في
برلين اجراء عمليه على قدمه اليسرى اثرى
اصابتها خلال تمارين رياضيه لكنه خرج من
غرفه العمليات بقدمين معطوبتين الشاب قال
للصحفيين ان الممرضه سالته بعد العمليه هل
القدم كتؤلمك فاجاب نعم يوجد الم في القدم
اليمنى لترد الممرضه لتطمئنه بقولها هذا
امر طبيعي لانها خضعت لعمليه جراحيه وهنا
صدم الشاب الذي قرر لاحقا مقاضاه ادارات
هذه المستشفى بسبب هذا الخطا الفالح